los puntos más álgidos de la relación
comercial entre el reino unido y la
unión europea- ya están pactados pero
todavía quedan temas sobre la mesa uno
de los que más le preocupa españa es la
frontera con gibraltar un territorio
británico localizado en el sur de la
península ibérica y por cuya frontera
pasan diariamente 15.000 personas
madrid- quiere evitar una frontera dura
y se prepara ante la falta de una puerta
para aquellos trabajadores
transfronterizos que hayan se hayan
registrado porque eran trabajadores
transfronterizos con anterioridad a el
primero de enero del 2021
estos ciudadanos podrán moverse
identificándose con un documento
preparado al efecto del lado británico
los críticos señalan que el acuerdo
entre londres y bruselas no protege a
todos por igual y el trato es un acuerdo
frágil no proporciona la protección
adecuada para la fabricación británica
nuestros servicios financieros las
industrias creativas o los derechos
laborales
y es que todavía es una incógnita como
compañías de seguros o bancos británicos
podrían operar en la unión europea pero
el gobierno de boris johnson insiste en
que esta es la oportunidad para
convertir a londres en la capital de los
servicios financieros
por ejemplo examinamos cómo hacemos de
londres el lugar más atractivo para las
nuevas compañías en cualquier parte del
mundo en the world tampoco es claro como
los británicos reemplazarán los sistemas
de seguridad que brinda la unión europea
para rastrear en vivo alertas
terroristas ni hay un acuerdo final para
garantizar el flujo de datos de europeos
que usan las organizaciones británicas y
viceversa